لا تطيق الناشطه الاوكرانيه تتيانا رؤيه
تمثال شمس الشعر الروسي الكسندر بوشكين في
عاصمه بلادها وتدعو الى ازالته ليست وحدها
فثمت حملات لالاف الاوكرانيين تطالب
بالامر ذاته شاب غاضب كتب هنا ازيلوا واخر
ذهب الى التعبير بسبب هؤلاء يقتل ابنائنا
نصل ازاله كل ما يتعلق بالتراث الروسي من
تماثيل واسماء لان روسيا تعتدي على
اوكرانيا وتتسبب بالكثير من الالام لنا
الاديب والروائي الروسي ماكسيم جوركي لم
يصمد امام مشاعر الغضب تغير اسم هذا
الشارع واصبح
نسبه الى روائي اوكراني بدلا من شيكالوفا
الطيار السوفيتي مجلس البلديه بالعاصمه
يؤكد تغيير اسماء مئتين وسبعه وثلاثين
شارعا دعاه الازاله يطالبون بالحفاظ على
اللغه الاوكرانيه ايضا في هذا الملجا تحت
الارض حرص على تعليم الطلاب باللغه
الاوكرانيه دون ان تنازعها في ذلك الروسيه
كما كان في السابق
معركه الهويه هنا امتدت للكنيسه فالصراع
الذي بدا في 2014 ساهم في الانفصال بين
بطريركيه
ما تزال موسكو ترفض استقلال الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه في اوكرانيا وتحرض ضدنا ولكن
العالم الارثوذكسي يعترف بنا وهذا هو
الاهم رسم هذا الشرخ في اعلى قوس تمثال
الصداقه لم يبقى فلقد ازيل اليوم ما كان
يسمى رمز الصداقه الروسيه الاوكرانيه وفي
موازاه ذلك تمت من يرى انه يجب الحفاظ على
التاريخ والارث لا سيما وان اثار القرنين
الماضيين لا تزال ماثله وفي مقدمتها هذه
النجمه السوفيتيه يسعى كثير من
الاوكرانيين الى الانفكاك عن كل ما يربطهم
بالروس كما يقولون في مقابل رغبه متزايده
للتقارب مع اوروبا والنيتو
وصولا الى مسماه اليوم الساحه الاوروبيه
فمعركه الوعي والهويه وازاله التبعيه
لروسيا مستمره في اوكرانيا حسن الشوبكه
الجزيره كير